it is so nice getting to talk to you
obviously I've been a huge fan for years
my favorite thing about your show is
that it shows a side of you that we
don't normally get to see why did you
decide to open up this restoration
project you know not just in front of a
camera crew but inviting along an
audience for the ride oh I just think
it's a it's an interesting project and I
got kind of obsessed with you know
cooking shows and and all these crazy
like you know building shows on TV I
didn't even know how to work like these
the
these apps and everything before the
pandemic and I started watching all
these things and I thought they were so
great and just being here and puttering
around and and kind of realizing the the
potential of the place and that I could
really do something special I just my
HTTP came up to me and I just said sure
yes without a lot of thought because I
think it's really fun to
um just see the progression it's it has
a lot of history and it's just nice that
I came from here and I went all around
the world I came back in one piece which
is a miracle and then I said all my
archives here and everything that was
important to me so unloading them and
and building this place is just a real
therapeutic experience for me and I and
I thought why not
gives me more resources to actually
create the project that I want to create
too which is there's 12 more buildings
to build there's barns there's all sorts
of stuff so it's just the beginning it's
not even close to being done but every
day we do a little something to make it
a little better it's definitely a daily
a daily I'm working every day in the
garden it's crazy I love that I love
that so much you say right off the top
of the show that you know when it comes
to your life you've had an interesting
journey and that you're surprised after
20 years that you've come back to Canada
back to your family's property what is
the most special thing about this
property for you
like it was always My Sanctuary it was
always my Saving Grace I knew that if I
kept this place so I could keep one foot
on Vancouver Island I could kind of
handle anything out there which I did
you know I had quite a wild little
experience and you know it's not over
yet but at least I have here to keep me
grounded and when I'm here I like to get
my hands dirty I like to get into the
dirt I love the garden with my mom and
it just was really important to me to
keep it and I almost lost it a few times
but I really just went on to it knowing
that one day I come back here and that
um I'd have my parents move on to the
property I want to be closer to them in
their Elder years and have a family
gathering place the kids will have their
kids and I'm hoping everyone comes here
at some point so I'm building it so they
will come
Field of Dreams I love that
I love seeing your parents they seem so
sweet the meaning behind the Rose Garden
wow so special uh how proud are they of
you knowing that you are bringing this
property back to its original Glory
well my dad was always like Pamela I
just want to see a whole dog on that
property you know before I go and like
just something's gonna happen because
and so much more has happened than that
obviously and so he's just loving it
he's sitting on his deck watching it all
being built he's getting involved when
he wants to and my mom too we're just
we're doing you know so much work here
together it's fun I mean I think it's we
never recommend it it was 30 years I
bought it 30 years ago and I just left
it abandoned so there was a lot of work
to do even to get it to it was you know
it's kind of a place called chicken
cheerful livable place because it's
rotted and and you know and falling
apart so that was the first level and
then last year was another level that we
did just kind of pretty it up and get
better appliances and things like that
in their houses and now we're building
new buildings so getting exciting it's
just it's a monster project but it's my
masterpiece and it's really important to
me I this is who I am this is the
foundation of love I didn't have this
place I don't think I could have
survived you know even the even the
crazy Readiness of the world that I was
in I just always when things were going
wild around me I always thought well I
always have time to go to I always have
nothing to go to
go to that is so important and you know
it's interesting you lived you've lived
in the US for more than two decades now
when you first left Canada to find work
in the U.S was that an exciting time for
you
well I mean it it kind of found me I
didn't go to America looking for the
work but it just kind of like the the
story just kind of unraveled and I was
offered to go and I went and didn't
expect to stay I always said I'd just
stay in America until I'm not working
anymore but I just keep working that's
working but you know that I've always
had here which was really important and
it's great I really want my kids to have
this place too because it's it's really
easy to kind of get swept up in that
world and you never can keep your feet
on the ground somehow and I don't know
if I'm really known for being a very
grounded person but when I'm here I'm
just you know I'm just me I go right
back to my childhood I'm I'm the girl
that you know runs around Barefoot and
gets in trouble I'm mischievous and you
know talking to the trees and the
Animals looking for fairies in my garden
you know just it's the same space same
thing that's my favorite thing about
this series on one minute you're in your
high heels which I love to see and then
the next minute you're in your bare feet
like it just I feel like this really
encompasses who you truly are deep down
which is so fun for the audience to see
was there a moment when you knew it was
time to come home after living in the
states
while I was traveling a lot and I um my
parents were getting older my dad had a
stroke a few years ago he was made a
full comeback he's doing really well but
I just felt like I was so far away also
my kids I wanted to give them enough
space be close enough and I need to go
home I need to go home and start that
project I just need to dive into it
because that's where
everyone's gonna come home too no matter
what happens in the world we always have
it just kind of gave me a little boost
in this direction and and I thought that
I would be traveling a little more but
with a pandemic I was kind of stuck here
which was a good one and I just never
stopped gardening and building and it's
become this really incredible spot where
I think it's only going to get more and
more beautiful and it's endless it's an
endless project I know that and it's fun
to work with contractors and work with
different people that bring their own
experience to it and their own talents
even if you don't agree with them all
the time
that's my crazy Vision like I want to
live in a birdhouse I want to live in a
floating egg or I want and people just
look at me like
but
somewhere between my brain and reality
I love that you use the words magical
and peaceful when you're describing this
property do you have that same sense of
Peace anywhere else in the world or is
this it this is it this is it if I
didn't I get chilled thinking about it
because there's something very like even
volcanic it's something there's a real
uh a dream really vividly here I get
great ideas here I wrote my whole book
from here I just feel like this is
this is it's it's just packed full of
full of energy and history with the man
and it just feels like when I say it's
my safe Zone and I know I'm sharing it
with the world but I also feel like it's
a great Testament to you know family and
how if you build something they will
come like really and I really think it's
important to
um you know for me it's important to
look after my parents and I always have
and I always will but it's love to it's
nice to have them close by grandparents
are the best and they're the most
amazing grandparents and dog names
you're really good with the dogs too so
it's like we just have a lot of fun
together and I can see it like me when I
bought this place I could see it I could
see it there's certain things have
happened to me in my life where I can
visualize something that was going to
happen and this was one of those things
and so I'm really excited to share it
because
it's just fun it's not like we're not
following any Trends it's not fancy like
ranchy rustic even the cooking I'm doing
a lot of cooking and canning and
pickling and my garden is exploding and
who would have thought that I could I
would be a good Gardener but it's like
Jack and the Beanstalk over there like
we have every flexible and I can't keep
up with the tomatoes I'm making every
kind of tomato sauce mixed with rose
gold I'm throwing everything in I'm
Googling is it poisonous
it's not good so anyway it's been a
blast it's been great making bread all
the time and you know and you know in my
gardening clothes I've got my you know
my aprons and my gardening gloves and
gardening tools and everything I look at
everything like a picture and I think
probably I got that from my career but
just everything I just I look around and
I think everything's a picture of the
ocean and the dogs and the fields and
the meadows and the buildings and it's
it's just um it's an art project
my art project it's my masterpiece
I love that when you say this is your
Masterpiece and you're watching this
series that is the perfect word to
describe this my favorite thing to learn
about you is that not only do you like
ironing and laundry but you like doing
it with wine I love the wine I
understand that but why do you like
laundry so much
it's meditative it's just like mowing
the lawn I love mowing the lawn too I
have a push mower and I have six acres
and I actually the last time I mowed the
lawn I did it with a push mower which
was crazy I have a factor and I've used
that on occasion but it's not as fun
it's just like in the lines you can do
with them I mean I'm really exam and
everything I I it's meditative it's
you know doing something consistently
like that it just feels comforting and
yeah and you know and I'm I wear a lot
of linen so I need to iron and steam and
do that kind of stuff and I don't have
to trust anybody else with it
I don't know why I just I mean I love
laundry and I love clotheslines and
bedding and I just have this whole
romantic kind of look on building a like
a family kind of home where it's not too
fancy not I don't have a lot of people
working here I'd like to do it I love to
cook I love to clean I love to do all
that kind of stuff so it's and I love to
Garden I mean I didn't know that I was
such a good Gardener I always knew my
mom was an incredible green thumb but I
definitely am doing a good job my roses
are just you know there there's
thousands of them it seems I can't keep
up with it oh I love that that's so
rewarding because they're they're tricky
roses are tricky to grow roses are
tricky and I have the specific you know
these specific roses that I love these
PJ roses are really hard to get and I
and I every kind of every flower
arrangement that I've ever had from from
different you know people in my life
they've always Incorporated PJ and I
thought why don't I just get them right
so I planted 75 bare root of didn't
think they were going to survive and
they exploded they're doing so well and
I don't think I'm the best pruner I'm
definitely doing it wrong but I'm
learning you have to fail to learn and
I'm getting a lot of that
and it's very entertaining for us to
watch so thank you
horrified probably but it was fun doing
it no I love that I also love seeing
your incredible collection of shoes your
beautiful
outfits from Chanel McQueen Eve Saint
Laurent I mean the list goes on and on I
don't normally ask this but is there a
day in the future I could come over just
try a few of those outfits on sure you
know by the way I felt like I gave
everything away and then I'm opening
these boxes I'm going oh my God I'm a
hoarder oh my God what's going on I have
way too much stuff so I'm still giving
things away but you know and I do
believe in Simplicity and not hanging on
to everything but I have camped
everything I've kept my kids report
cards I've kept like I'm just like a
regular mom and then my whole life is
weird and TV shows you know I got a lot
of really beautiful clothes and I bought
a lot of things and I had a lot of gifts
and I have shoes I don't I need to build
a closet is what I need to do that's
next
again
when it comes to the cabin The Roadhouse
and Boathouse what are you most excited
to see fully complete
nothing is complete everything's just so
by little I mean the Garden is like it's
it's like nothing is complete there's
just you know like the Roadhouse there's
still things to do the cabin is still
things to do because I'm moving my
parents actually moved into the cabin
finally and now I'm building up their
own cabin for them so it's just you know
we're kind of just camping in these
buildings it feels like nothing is done
but it it's just it's gonna take a
couple years yeah and then it's gonna be
great because you're gonna have a barn
with some residences there we're going
to have different clusters and cabins
and everything is going to be a garden
you're going to be able to pick
vegetables very problem so lavender and
tomatoes they're mixed together and I'm
just I just I need to have a plan that's
what my kids say because I'm not a
planner I'm like just do this and then
I'll do this and take that out and put
that over there but that's a kind of
really stupid expensive way to do things
you have to have a plan so Brandon has
kind of taken the reins and he's saying
mom we got to do this right we're gonna
we're all gonna agree on something and
then we're gonna stick to it
you would have thought he would have
been around
I love that and it's so nice you know
not only are you building these memories
for your kids in the future but just
knowing that that there's like that Bond
there with you and Brandon doing all
this
yeah and Dylan you know his girlfriend
is a budding a designer so I'm going to
be using her a lot too and I feel like
it's
it's just fun to keep it in the family I
mean it just feels like this is like a
these all these decisions have to be
family made and you know we're not
talking to the trains we're not trying
to be the only thing that we are trying
to do would be sustainable if possible
and you know we're going to be water
catching and we're and we've been um and
I've got solar panels and as much of
that as we can because
um you know the world's heating up and
we need to figure out ways
to have this place be usable decades
down the road not just now yeah well I
know that you were a huge animal
activist and I love seeing the scene
with the owl the rescue and then of
course releasing the owl back onto your
property any updates with the owl
fun I mean I hear them all the time I
don't even know where they are because
now I have some I've got five dogs well
now the dog's running around the field
the owls have found other places to mess
up if they don't dare want to drop a
baby out again around these dogs
um so they're outside of the
um they're still on the property but
they're they're not in the center
anymore even though we put that picnic
basket up there and tried to help out
but I think they'll figure they figure
it out but I hear them all the time yeah
I love that you know Vancouver Island is
just so beautiful I mean just seeing the
scenery of this property is so great for
me as a Canadian when you come home to
Canada do you have a go-to Canadian
comfort food are we doing ketchup chips
Tim Hortons what's your go-to not
anymore not anymore I did better with a
pandemic I mean I'm I I count my carbs
I'm vegan you know I've got my proteins
all this crazy stuff now because I have
so much time on my hand people think I'm
crazy I get I've got my aura ring for my
sleep it's like a bit you know I need to
fill my time with craziness but um my
comfort food is just
um what I'm making in the garden
yesterday I made a vegan pumpkin pie
though which was fantastic and with real
me roasting the pumpkin not that pumpkin
milk pumpkin pie and um
it's just that the food has never really
been a top the top of my list but I'm
really enjoying this pickling and
canning and I could eat people beets
that's my anti-wise recipe too so it's
in the family family recipes
definitely love that uh Pamela Anderson
so nice getting to talk to you uh what a
window into your life thank you so much
for sharing this with us it's such a
good show I can't wait for everyone to
see it thanks